I'm having I'm having I'm having plenty  of cars right now that I don't have  anywhere to put anyway so I see you have  enough storage space here where's your  car I'll come let me just someone bring  you a cup of car I gotta do something  fun now let's do it I come up in y'all  John do some fun man let's do it maybe  that's the next you know your next visit  you can come look at your own car ya  know I don't come look up come grab my  head it's all that looking I'm coming to  drive like I don't do that I Drive my  car they're gonna drive my ride or  something like that you know but I got a  few extra cars ain't been really you  know just been sitting up in a little  chance you know  yeah man man you gonna do mine let's do  it  serious time it's time serious man